Good morning John! Time for a truth bomb.
You and I have had a good
month
but you gotta admit that there's no way
we could do any of the things that we do
without this community.
Frankly, Nerdfighteria is my biggest inspiration
That means that when I don't have an idea for a video
I can just ask on Twitter, and Tumblr, and also Instagram
though Instagram on the internet doesn't show me all the comments
Why? Why?! That's not a complicated feature!
Show more.  Gimme a link.
That's right, I'm already doing it
I'm taking your suggestions on what I should do in my video today.
[musical transition]
That was a good idea.
[Brazilian Music Transition]
I'm here today with a sidewalk
to talk about what it's like to be a sidewalk.
So sidewalk, what do you think?
Sidewalk - "Well, I got no complaints, except tree roots."
Sidewalk - "Don't get me started on tree roots."
Fascinating.
[Singing] One day I had an idea when I was bored.
[singing] I was like, Bernie, what do you think if the people from Pride and Prejudice were vloggers?
[singing] I never thought that idea would win an Emmy award,
[singing] and the fact that so people like it is totally bonkers!
[guitar strumming]
This is a book you may have heard of.
It's called Emma. It's by Jane Austen.
And some friends of mine are about to adapt it into a video blog series.
So maybe you want to read up?
[Strange Charm musical transition]
I want a Wonder Woman movie, right?
Like, that needs to exist. Did you know that Joss Whedon wanted to do one,
and Warner Brothers turned him down?
The person who made that decision needs to eat a can of poop flavored poop.
[Musical Transition]
Pretty good, actually.
I was all ready to talk about how terrible this was.
Hm.
OOOOWWWW!
OOWWW!
[Musical Transition]
[Incoherent noises]
Ow.
[Musical Transition]
I deal with stress in two ways,
'cos there are two kinds of stress:
There's stress that you can take care of
and there's stress that you can't.
The first one, I take care of it as fast as possible
because putting it off always makes it worse.
Things that I can't fix, I think about the fact that I can't fix them. I think about why I can't fix them,
and I come to terms with the fact that this is a problem that I am not going to overcome
and the world is not a wish granting factory.
[Musical Transition]
Alright, Speech Jammer. Already downloaded it.
Putting my headphones on. This is a very long cord.
This is the free one we're going to st-st-
Speech Jamm...er's work by playing your voice back into your ears right after you speak.
It interferes with the cog-cognitive cognitive cog-
It becomes- It becomes diff- difficult to make sure-
[Incoherent noise]
It's very difficult to speak.
[Musical Transition]
[Twerking Musical Transition]
Things are going good. SciShow and Crash Course are going well.
SciShow just hit a million subscribers. Subabble, I should talk about.
This is a difficult thing, launching a product, and we had a snafu with Amazon and the ability
to take recurring payments, so if you set up a monthly subscribership, it got cancelled out.
So you need to go back to Subbable, sign in and re-up your subscription
because Amazon freaked out on us because we weren't following all their rules correctly.
Now we are.
Subbable has been extremely successful and if everybody goes back in
and actually redoes their subscription, then Crash Course is going to be safe,
bur right now, only 50% of people have done that, so if you haven't, please do.
Thanks for all the fantastic ideas. This was a really weird video.
John, I'll see you on Tuesday.
[Musical Ending]